and also i went to egypt um like a month
ago
and for a couple of weeks and got an
education there and learning about
how what i'm going to say sort of like
was part of it was learned over their
experience but
this patriarchy that essentially what i
feel like happened was
my opinion back in the egyptian days
you'll go and we'll look at all these
temples and
pyramids but really the temples are
where everything has the writing and the
hieroglyphs and
um the the the stories all included a
triad
which is a a man a woman and a child
and then essentially like it became the
trinity holy trinity
and then women were gone and the romans
came in and
their religion and god i know religion
is so deep for you and goes back
all the way to childhood what cradle
were you catholic
yeah um so
you know and it feels like the romans
came in and all the they they chipped
all the faces
off of everything in egypt like all the
be all the beautiful
you know walls and everything they chip
the faces off and i'm like holy crap
it feels like that's kind of when the
patriarchy really like went
upswing and you know women were sort of
taken out of the equation for everything
everything was not only revised but you
know
all the men were writing it to their own
to suit their own
vision and ego and purpose
yeah yeah and i mean even the the
pervasive message that there is such
thing
as better than worse than whether it's
gender or
you know that beautiful book cast um you
know
the idea that there's better or worse is
just pretty comical
it doesn't mean you're not faster you're
a faster runner or driver or
doesn't mean doesn't mean we don't have
different capacities it just means
the value our value is equal
you know i mean that's patriarchy is
completely
anathema to the idea of egalitarianism
it's
it's it's so violent
really atlantis it's violated patriarchy
tell me more about that
it feels like it's operating out of the
ego so much more like a woman just like
i've heard it a lot lately but then
every now and again there'll be
a man that will reflect it back and
they'll be like like
women just can do more you just have
more love you just have
more more more like you're just more of
things
and um at the core of it though just you
know creating and
and you know creating life and have just
more love inside it's not that you can't
a man can't love
but women just kind of lead with the
heart a little bit more and so if
like on the sort of like uh heels of you
talking about
how you how you um school your children
and how you teach them it's like
you're teaching them how to love
themselves too like and if we can
shift from more of a patriarchal sort of
mindset of like fit in the box do this
thing get it done
right like there's so much rigidity to
it and
um like women leading are going to come
from that heart space
of like love and compassion and softness
and honoring yourself and how you're
feeling and how you're doing that day
and letting the day lead you as opposed
to following this
like highly doctrine rigid curriculum
where you start to have to detune and
detach from
yourself and your body and how you're
actually feeling
in order to operate like i know there's
such detachment and i think that part of
what we're moving into and i'm curious
if you think so
is into this space where we're learning
how to because we can't
how do we know what to trust do we trust
the news no do we trust the newspapers
no
do we trust even documentaries no who
the heck paid for
right like what was propaganda like we
don't even know what to trust anymore
and the only gauge we're going to learn
be that we need
the one that we need to learn how to use
is our body to give us the information
and it does and i think that only comes
through being able to tap into that
sort of the the feminine the femininity
within you
um and and that's just you know that's
that's woman
yeah and feminine even in man bodies and
non-gender identifying bodies too it's
like
the feminine is what has been murdered
by patriarchy right
yeah kind of the divine feminine
obviously i'm not trying to it's like
the femininity the divine feminine
verses
within within all of us so yes the
the easiest and and quickest path to
shifty patriarchy is to just start by
being respectful to women period
let's just start there um and then
beyond that it's also just honoring the
vulnerable honoring the
the water of it all you know but i think
what's happened now with how
much stimulation there is in the world
depending upon our temperament
you know there's it just gets too much
in here like i think i think we can do
100 things and now it just feels like
there's 300 things
so and that's just me personally um so i
i like i like that we have the capacity
to multitask
and my projection is to be careful with
that
because then life can sometimes take
advantage of it and patriarchy
definitely will take advantage of it
it'll just say give us everything you've
got
and we'll take it and see you later so
um
but i think you know this is a really
great time to be alive as a woman
and what i what i'm really keeping my
eye on in my own personal world
among many other things is is the the
cluttering
you know because if i'm gonna go
meditate there's a peter levine talks
about
i think he calls it anxiety or sorry
meditation-induced anxiety or something
like that
so those of us who go to meditate
basically the point is is that with
certain trauma meditating is not going
to actually help
because then we're left alone with these
thoughts or these ruminations or these
tapes that play
so so sometimes meditating alone is
actually not the way to go it depends on
where we're at i guess i feel like i
just went off on a great tangent
oh it's it's all just it's the
exploration
right it's it's trying to figure it out
it's trying to figure out what you need
and
you know i think that you do a really
good job of that and
um you know i think it's really cool
that you teach your kids i'm so
fascinated by all that
and and then you know like what we're
talking about with um
uh what's it um multiple intelligence i
mean
can you imagine if our world stepped
into a space where we all
learned what our intelligence was
instead of having to fit into a box like
i believe being biological beings that
there is a natural balance not only is
there a natural fix for everything that
is wrong with us and nature but also
that we
we are nature and that we balance each
other and so
imagine the beauty if we could all just
kind of contribute what we what was
what was what we were good at and
passionate about usually what we're
usually we're passionate about things
we're good at um and
and and how i feel i trust that there
would be a balance
in existence if we all just contributed
what we what was our natural
intelligence
i really completely agree with that